Some might argue that 2011's "The Thing" didn't
copy the 1982 original as well as the titular
monster does its victims, but fans seem to
disagree, judging by its popularity on Netflix.
Though some movies may not fair well during
their tenure as a theatrical release, there
is always a chance for a movie to gain new
viewership when it comes to streaming services.
Coughing up the amount of money required to
see a film typically makes some audiences
apprehensive, and it seems like the only movies
that make money these days are Avengers-level outings.
Luckily, Netflix is there to help gain some
new viewership for movies that may not have
been seen by a whole lot of people in theaters.
This is the case for 2011's "The Thing."
Open up the movie catalog on Netflix, and
"The Thing" is not just the first film many
viewers will see advertised, but it is also
the third most popular movie on Netflix at
this moment.
As a prequel/remake of 1982's "The Thing,"
the 2011 movie features the familiar and terrifying
story of an isolated research center located
in Antarctica.
Starring Joel Edgerton, Mary Elizabeth Winstead,
Adewale Akinnuoye-Agbaje, and Ulrich Thomsen,
"The Thing" seemed like it would be an absolute
slam dunk as a new iteration of the beloved
science-fiction classic.
Unfortunately, the 2011 version failed to
compel theatrical audiences, and some consider
it one of the worst sci-fi remakes of all
time.
"Burn it!"
"The Thing" tells the story of a far-flung
research settlement and its assortment of
scientists who soon find themselves under
attack by a shape-changing alien.
This plot is similar to the original version
from 1982, and the paranoia that these individuals
feel often drives the plot forward as they
wonder who can they trust when there is an
extraterrestrial organism that can kill, assimilate,
and mimic other forms of life.
Audiences at the time didn't feel the need
to check out the movie, and the film missed
the mark at the box office.
"The Thing" was made for $38 million, but
the movie failed to break even, generating
just shy of $17 million in the United States
and $10.5 million in international markets.
Besides just failing to make money, "The Thing"
received a middling reception, with Rotten
Tomatoes showing that the movie has a 34%
critic score and a 42% audience score.
Despite a lackluster reception, some critics
saw potential in the 2011 movie.
Keith & the Movies wrote,
"Fans of the 1982 classic will want to see
it and should find a lot to like.
While it trips itself up with an overloaded
cast and a few scenes which feel like they
belong in another film, it does deliver that
almost old-school sci-fi monster movie feel."
Although 2011's "The Thing" failed to garner
a lot of attention during its original run,
it's dominating Netflix at the moment.
Perhaps audiences were simply waiting for
an opportune time to watch the movie as the
original "The Thing" is considered a classic.
Now that 2011's version is just a click away,
it seems like viewers are giving the movie
another chance, even though there are major
changes from the original source material.
Director Matthijs van Heijningen Jr. spoke
with Den of Geek in 2012 about some of the
changes and ideas he had while approaching
2011's "The Thing," which included how he
helped rewrite the first version of the script
and had Kate Lloyd as the main character as
opposed to the original's R.J. Macready.
Heijningen added that the cast didn't need
much inspiration when taking on their respective roles.
He said,
"Everyone who was part of this saw and loved
John Carpenter's movie.
I didn't have to explain anything about that
sense of awkwardness because there was a great
example of it in the movie.
We saw the movie all together before we started.
So it all felt very natural — it was already
familiar to everybody."
The similarities to the original film, as
well as the difference, seem to finally have
been embraced thanks to Netflix.